I would like everybody t-, to uh, to try and laugh without smiling.
I just pictured Hannah doing this!
You're totally smiling!
I am not!
Hank: Do you want to see the replay?
Hank: You are.
Hannah: nooo
I can't! I can't do it!
Flula: Oh biscuit.
Hank: I like how dead your eyes are.
I want all girlfriends to tell me that after dates.
I didn't think I would hate it as much as I do, but I hate it so much.
I feel like I'm killing my heart.
What weird experiment are you putting me through right now?
Seems weird, like a creeper.
Like you're going insane right?
I cannot!
Uh, nope.
Ruba: Take three!
Hank: One more.
Hank: You're too good!
Mark: It's almost like I'm actually soulless.
I can't!
I'm so creeped out by myself, I can't even see my own face.
Sounds like I'm crying!
Hank: You're smiling a lot!
Duuuuudeee
Trick's on you, I've never laughed in my life!
And I just, you know, make that noise and everyone believes it.
Oh that's easy!
Oooh, that's uncomfortable.
I feel sad.
Wait, am I supposed to try to laugh without...
Err, no.
It's so hard!
That's so weird!
Hank: That's good, that's good!
Let's hope I didn't spit on your lens!
The whole laughing without smiling thing, it's been done before.
And, it's something that the do in the VidCon office all the time to relieve stress,
to make each other laugh,
to make themselves laugh.
I think that's what I like about it, is a lot of the time, you start out fake laughing,
and then it makes you real laugh, and real laughing is nice.
And the VidCon team, right now, is in Anaheim doing all the checkups and visits and meetings and stuff
that we need to do getting ready for VidCon because it's happening
earlier this year, it's June 24th. You think I'd know!
June 23rd to 25th, so I was right.
Kind of.
If you like online video, VidCon is a thing that we do. I hope you can come.
So glad I got to see all those people while I was in LA.
They're all great, there's lots of them and I put links to all their channels in the description.
And there was one person that you didn't see in the video laughing without smiling
so let's do that while I link to all the other collab videos that I was in while I was in LA,
the ones that have come out so far, at least.
Here we go!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.